la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
dominti monsieur ministre chargé des
transports de la pêche et de la mer
monsieur le ministre en 2012 36 % des
trains de la ligne D du R étit considéré
comme irrégulier par l'association
d'usagers sadure établissant ainsi un
nouveau
record la qualité du service des
transports en commun parisien est un
véritable cauchemar au quotidien
incident en tout genre prix toujours en
hausse sentiment d'insécurité croissant
propreté qui laisse à
désirer
merci 142 incidents ont été
relevés dans les pages de notre
quotidien régional Le Parisien en dit en
2009 272 en
2010 324 incidents en 2011 et je ne
parle que d'incid monsieur le ministre
il ne s'agit pas des mouvements sociaux
qui on le sait dans cette activité sont
rarement
rares la faute c'est que le diagnostic
n'a pas été prise en compte il y a eu
une hausse de 1 million 700000 usagers
parisiens ou en tout cas franilien
pendant cette période pendant ce
temps-là la durée de vie moyenne du
matériel roulant lui est estimé dans un
rapport de la Cour des comptes à 26 ans
alors qu'on sait que dans ce type
d'activité la durée maximale est l'ordre
de 30
ans les Parisiens mérite une
considération pour les transport en
commun je sais que vous êtes un élu
local attaché au fonctionnement et de
des transports dans votre région or à
Paris les Parisiens ont l'habitude
d'être maltraités maltraités parce que
depuis la guerre l'État exerce le
monopole nous sommes dans la seule
région française où il y a ce monopole
d'État nous sommes dans la seule région
d'Europe où il y a un monopole d'État et
nous sommes peut-être encore l'une des
particularités dans le monde où nous
avons ce système qui perdure puisque pas
moins de quatre sociétés d'État
s'occupent normalement de ce système de
transport ce système qui est défaillant
le dernier rapport qui a été fait n'a
même pas procédé à l'audition de maire
de Paris il n'a pas été consulté il y a
eu deux adjoints qui se sont intéressés
mais le maire de Paris n'a pas été
impliqué dans la problématique du
développement de la Société du Grand
Paris la Société du Grand Paris c'est
une initiative du président Sarkozi pour
essayer de résoudre dans l'urgence ce
système la voie qui a été prise n'est
pas la voie qui semble la plus efficace
puisqueencore une fois c'est celle du
monopole public pour autant elle avait
le mérite de fixer un objectif clair il
semblerait que votre gouvernement hésite
il n'a pas affecté le milliard
nécessaire au budget 2013 tel qu'il
était prévu le Premier ministre a
annoncé que le 3 janvier qu'il
arbitrerait sur un certain nombre de
dispositions et pendant ce temps-là les
Parisiens attendent c'était l'objet de
ma
question merci la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric cuviler ministre chargier des
Transports de la mer et de la
Pêche merci merci Monsieur le monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Sénateur je
vais répondre mais votre question est
dense en interpellation et en sujet je
vais répondre pour ce qui est de ma
compétence mais vous avez signalé qu'il
s'agissait de monopole que vous semblez
regretter monopole d'état vous verrez
dans ma le développement de ma réponse
combien il peut aussi il y avoir des
apports heureux dans la prise en charge
efficace c'est en tout cas ce que
j'essis de faire depuis maintenant
quelques mois mais vous me m'interpellez
sur un passif qui est plus ancien vous
en conviendrez et donc en quelques mois
même si nous réorientons la politique
des transports pour la rendre plus
efficace le débit ne peut-être mis à
l'activité de ce gouvernement mais nous
sommes très attachés à ce que vous
considérez être un droit pour les
Parisiens ce que et les Franciliens ce
que je vous accorde volontiers
c'est-à-dire la régul
la qualité de service et le fait que le
transport qui est le transport du
quotidien puisse être une priorité et
d'ailleurs la commission du
développement durable de l'Assemblée
nationale organise demain une table
ronde sur les transports en île-de-fance
avec les présidents de la SNCF et de la
RATP d' RFF également j'ai vu les deux
présidents hier de la de la SNCF et RFF
la direction générale du STIF et
l'association des usagers de transport
d'Île-de-France et je m'en félicite
parce que effectivement vous parlez de
dysfonctionnement ils peuvent être tout
à fait d'origine
différent les causes en sont multiples
et pas nécessairement des défaillances
matérielles mais quoi qu'il en soit
c'est une préoccupation que de pouvoir
limiter au maximum les conséquences de
dysfonctionnement et c'est ce que j'ai
demandé à l'ensemble des dirigeants
d'entreprise RATP SNCF RFF et c'est
aussi l'enjeu de liens que je peux avoir
avec le syndicat de transport
d'Île-de-France qui rassemble région
département et qui est l'organisation
organisatrice des l'autorité
organisatrices des transports franilien
les nouveaux contrats entre le STIF et
les deux entreprises publiques ratpsncf
portant sur la période 2012-2015 ont été
signés dès le printemps 2012 et sont
marqués par un renforcement des
exigences du stitif notamment en matière
de qualité de service et de suivi des
programmes d'investissement vous en
soullignez la faiblesse et bien je vais
pouvoir répondre à ce niveau à ce niveau
euh une exigence nouvelle dans la
réalisation de l'offre a été fortement
relevée avec notamment un accent qui a
été mis sur la ponctualité la régularité
et un système de bonus malus renforcé
pour les deux entreprises je partage et
d'ailleurs souhaité demander qu'il en
soit ainsi les objectifs mis en œuvre
par le STIF sur le plan du matériel
roulant soullignez le retard pris en la
matière le programme de rénovation
cofinancé à parité par le STIF et les
entreprises portant sur 119 RAM du RERB
et
venu renouveler la totalité de ce parc
et s'achèvera en 2014 par ailleurs sur
le plan des infrastructures des travaux
de modernisation financés par l'État et
la région sont en cours notamment sur le
RERB au nord le projet sera mise en
service en 2013 et a pour objectif
général d'améliorer les conditions de
transport des voyageurs des travaux sur
ce
RB permettra de faire circuler sur deux
voies des voies dédiées ce RER
améliorant ainsi la ponctualité une
desserte simplifiée renforcée devenant
omnibus et en heure de pointe aura une
régularité tous les 3 minutes départ
garde du Nord pour desservir
alternativement aéroport charles- de
Gaulle mitriclé dans la continuité de
ces action le STIF a lancé des travaux
d'amélioration du schéma directeur du
RERB au sud afin d'améliorer la qualité
de service consolider l'exploitation et
l'État appuie ce projet il est aussi
indispensable comme pour le rerc et d
qu'une action globale soit mise en œuvre
tant pour l'exploitation que
l'investissement et d'améliorer le
fonctionnement de ces lignes le
gouvernement réfléchit actuellement cet
élogjet de notre rencontre hier en lien
avec la région et le STIF au moyen
d'accélérer l'investissement dans les
trains du quotidien d'Île-de-France
concernant la gestion de lignes le STIF
incite également les entreprises à
poursuivre leur action pour unifier
l'exploitation de la ligne B la relève
en garde du Nord a été supprimée dans la
continuité de cette opération la RATP
SNCF vont mettre en place cet été un
centre de commandement unique et j'ai
demandé qu'une réflexion soit lancée sur
le Rea à l'image de ce qui s'est produit
s'agissant de la Société du Grand Paris
vous en connaissez les limites puisque
elle n'a pas vocation à gérer mais elle
une ligne mais la vocation à construire
des réseaux de métro
automatique je vais simplement vous dire
nous ne sommes pas dans laindécision
avec Cécile Duflot euh nous sommes en
train de pouvoir hiérarchiser euh les
interventions et les investissements qui
sont utiles au au voyage du euh au
transport du quotidien pour les
franciliens et les Parisiens je dis
simplement que la polémique sur les 10
sur le milliard n'a pas lieu d'être
puisque précisément les comptes précise
bien que celui-ci ne sera utilisé et
nécessaire qu'à horizon de 2014 plutôt
2000 5 et donc lorsqu'il sera nécessaire
de provisionner nous provisionnerons
mais ce qui est important c'est de
mobiliser tous les moyens rapidement à
la fois pour des réalisations des
aménagements qui sont des aménagements
ponctuels mais utiles et également de
faire avancer le grand schéma sur le
Grand Paris je sais pas pas vous auriez
pu poser la question à Cécile Duflot qui
en charge précisément le Grand Paris
ceci étant pour le volet transport nous
travaillons de concert et sachez bien
que conformément à l'engagement du
président de la République public la
question du transport du quotidien de sa
régularité de son efficacité est une
préoccupation qui est majeure vous avez
souligner que en tant que ministre des
Transports j'étais attentif à la qualité
de service dans ma région mais pas
seulement dans ma région monsieur le
sénateur dans toutes les régions et
particulièrement en Île-de-France dont
on connaît l'utilité l'intensité et la
nécessité d'avoir un service public de
qualité je m'y attache et je suis
heureux de pouvoir compter sur votre
mobilisation merci monsieur dominetti
monsieur le ministre je concède
évidemment tout à fait que ce n'est pas
à vous qui êtes responsable du bilan
catastrophique de l'état des transports
en Île-de-France vous vous venez de
prendre vos fonctions et je suis ravi
d'avoir pu vous sensibiliser à ce
problème particulier de la situation
spécifique de l'Île-de-France parce que
euh vous avez fait une réponse fournie
mais qui est celle du STI nous la
connaissons nous à Paris la réponse du
STIF ça fait de mandats que Monsieur
Huchon est à la tête de la région
île-de-fance qu'il préside le STIF et
c'est toujours la même chose on va
améliorer la qualité on va rénover du
matériel mais la Cour des comptes
lorsqu'elle fait un bilan elle dit 26
ans d'âge vous parlez du Grand Paris
vous dites c'est pas un problème le
milliard c'est pas un problème on en a
pas besoin tout de suite mais les
Parisiens eux payent maintenant la taxe
spéciale d'équipement ils l'ont payé dès
cette année plus de 10 € par foyer ça
c'est la réalité pourquoi le
gouvernement ne rend pas l'argent au
Parisien ça c'est la réalité parce que
Paris est maltraité en ce qui concerne
ces grandes institutions ou ces grandes
société national que vous protégez en
partie alors que lorsque vous étiez dans
l'opposition vous étiez d'accord pour
dire qu'effectivement en réalité le
système est engoncé il est bloqué et il
mérite d'être rénové je vous fais une
suggestion pourquoi la Société du Grand
Paris s'occupe de la construction doit à
10 milliards près faire un budget
puisqueapparemment le dépassement est
près de 10 milliards et la RTP pendant
ce temps-là n'a pas les moyens et bien
écoutez simplifieré donner mission à la
RTP de terminer ce réseau qui est en
réalité un réseau régional pour une
société la RATP qui est une société
nationale donc 98 % de son activité est
régionale autoriser les lignes de bus à
des compagnies privées ça allégera le
fardeau de la RATP parce que il faut pas
être spécialiste dans le monde entier
dans la France entière dans l'Europe
entière les lignes de bus ne sont pas un
monopole d'État voilà par exemple deux
idées vous êtes ministre des transport
euh je vous donne une piste